all right everybody so i want to talk
today with you about
who really rigged the 2020 election i
know there's been a lot of talk about
voter fraud and voter irregularities but
there is one
sure truth the media rigged the 2020
elections
tim grosclose is a professor of
political science over at ucla and he's
written about media bias
and he wrote years and years and years
ago that media bias liberal media bias
in the united states was worth about
eight to ten points for democrats in any
given election his suggestion was that
if all the media outlets in 2008
had shifted even as far left as the new
york times then barack obama would not
have won 52-46
over john mccain he would won 61-38 over
john mccain
right the idea being that as the media
shift left they shift perceptions and
how people think
the last four years have been a non-stop
wild ride
of media malpractice shifting wildly to
the left
lying to you and that shifted americans
opinions certainly was enough to shift
hundreds of thousands millions of votes
across the country the media lied to you
for four years they abandoned
their supposed objectivity they did so
in pursuit of orange man bad
they may have undercut their own
institutional ability to survive
if orange man bad is indeed deemed to
have lost the election
but here's the bottom line this election
was not fair
it was not fair specifically because the
media have formed a triumvirate along
with their friends in the democratic
party
and in social media to suppress
information that they don't want you to
see
and to push narratives that are simply
untrue so i want to go through some of
those
with you today because it really is true
that we're the media
less biased we're the media even close
to the objective observer of facts that
they pretend that they are
donald trump would have won this
election going away not just because the
economy was booming up until covet but
because all of the narratives that the
media focused on
were overtly false okay so first we got
to talk a little bit about how the
system works
okay so you have as i say this
triumvirate you have the democratic
party the democratic party formulates
the message
the message is always that republicans
are responsible for everything now
in that way they're no different than
the republican party would be on the
other side right the democrats are
responsible
for everything the difference is the
democratic party has in its pocket
the mainstream media 93 percent by last
polling again and 93
of people in newsrooms say they vote
democrat you cannot find a single
trump supporter anywhere at the new york
times they do not exist you can't find a
single trump voter
anywhere on the air at cnn unless
they're being paid as sort of the the
straw man to beat up they just don't
exist the editorial hierarchy
and most of our establishment media
institutions they just do
they don't include anybody who is to the
right of hillary clinton
just does not exist well what that means
is that they just repeat all the
democratic talking points and then the
democratic party
and the media combine to pressure the
one arena
in american life where they're supposed
to be free and open dissemination of
information typically conservatives have
fought back
against liberal media dominance by
building their own institutions right we
built daily wire here
right we built the ben shapiro show
daily caller exists breitbart exists
blaze tv exists fox news exists
and all of these exist in the arena
particularly online
of free distribution of information and
social media made that possible right
facebook made that possible and twitter
made that possible
so democrats in the media fought back
and the way they fought back is by
working with woke staffers inside these
big tech companies in order to suppress
messages they don't like and to suppress
outlets they don't like and so there is
this game where
members of the media basically start
suggesting
along with members of the democratic
party that even the free and open
dissemination of information on social
media is in fact russian disinformation
it's promulgating lies to the american
public
and so they hijack these supposed
platforms and then they turn the
platforms
into distribution mechanisms only for
their own narratives and only for their
own messages
and they shut down and suppress all of
the other messages and narratives and
facts
presented by the other side even if
those facts are true so this week
we saw this just the most obvious
example i've ever seen in my entire life
kevin roose who is a tech activist at
the new york times he's not a journalist
he's an activist
hey every day he tweets out a list of
various
articles that are performing well on
facebook this is designed specifically
in order to pressure facebook to shut
down those articles because what he will
say is why look at that
ben shapiro's page is performing really
well why look at that dan bongino's page
is performing really well oh my goodness
daily wire is getting heavy traffic via
facebook
that's because facebook is committed to
disinformation so you put out a tweet
and here is the tweet facebook is
absolutely teeming with right-wing
misinformation right now
these are all among the 10 most engaged
urls on the platform over the last
24 hours okay then he proceeded to
present four headlines
every single one of the headlines is
true one was from daily wire
two are from breitbart and one was from
pongino.com
every single one of those headlines was
factually true two of those headlines
were actually reported in similar terms
by the new york times itself the
publication he works for
so when he was called on this that this
isn't misinformation here is how kevin
roose responded he said quote
for the conservatives who are mad about
this yes it is possible for a story to
be factually accurate
and for it to be part of a
misinformation campaign
aimed at undermining confidence in an
election so in other words
it's not that he is targeting false
stories that are misinformation
he is targeting stories that are true
but do not back a narrative that he
likes
and this is the game this is the game
and social media
buys into it because social media is
staffed by silicon valley
liberals and woke staffers and they are
eager to jump
into that iron triangle democratic party
media social media they are eager to
jump in on the formation of that iron
triangle
and this is why you had in the in the
run-up to the election
social media censoring and suppressing
all information related to for example
hunter biden
right that story was suppressed by
twitter jack dorsey himself
acknowledged to congress that the new
york post story was not misinformation
they had no information that it was
misinformation here's jack dorsey saying
exactly that
do anybody have any any information
whatsoever they're not authentic or that
they are russian disinformation
darcy we we don't you know what
so so why would why would you censor it
why did you prevent that from
being disseminated on your platform that
is supposed to be
for the free expression of ideas and
particularly true ideas
we believe to fill a foul over hacking
materials policy
facebook suppressed the story
preemptively saying that he had to be
fact checked
okay well every story that is
distributed on facebook virtually has
yet to be fact checked when it's
originally posted
but that's the standard if it doesn't
agree with the narrative social media
will now suppress that
so that is the iron triangle by which
information is suppressed that is worth
points
in polls it is worth points in voting
booths to democrats
and you see that this iron triangle
between the democrats and the media
and social media to suppress the
narratives and to promulgate
particularly false narratives this has
had a long shelf life over the past few
years
overtly false narratives have been
pushed for years the most obvious false
narrative was the russian collusion
narrative we heard for years donald
trump was a cat's paw of vladimir putin
he's in putin's pocket he's some sort of
traitor
here are a bevy of media outlets saying
just that breaking news president trump
off the rails it was the beginning of
the end today
the beginning of the end breaking news
tonight new bombshell this is the
beginning of the end
the beginning of the end the walls are
closing in the walls closing in the
walls closing in it's over
the walls closing in the walls closing
in this is going to be the achilles hill
breaking news tonight
i expect trump to depart this week will
be the watershed week trump is in
big trouble trump's in a lot of trouble
it's a sign of a terrified old man who
feels the walls closing in the walls
are increasingly closing in on him
tonight the walls are closing in today
changed everything this is the beginning
of the end
that idea that trump is a threat to
american democracy because of russian
collusion that never materialized didn't
matter the media went for it all the way
and then they simply shifted
you'll remember that the editor of the
new york times dean baquette
the publisher of the new york times he
actually came out and he said after the
russian collusion thing fell apart he
said
i think we're going to restaff all of
our people to focus in on racism and
just like that
the narrative turned and suddenly the
focus went from donald trump
works for vladimir putin to donald trump
as white supremacist and magically
that became the narrative members of the
media just started repeating that donald
trump is a white supremacist
of course he doesn't denounce white
supremacy sonny because he is a white
supremacist
americans have to decide whether they
want a white supremacist
in the white house we've never had it
before maybe we didn't know we had it
but we certainly know we have it now
okay and then they decided not only to
lie about donald trump being a white
supremacist i mean for example john
roberts at fox had this exchange with
kaylee mcinnaty in which she literally
explained she reads him a list of quotes
in which donald trump says he is not a
white supremacist and hates white
supremacy
and john roberts of fox is like what if
i don't believe you
well who cares you're wrong as the
person who speaks for the president
does the president denounce white
supremacism and groups that espouse it
in all their forms this has been
answered yesterday by the president
himself the day before by the president
himself on the debate stage the
president was asked this he said sure
three times yesterday he was point blank
blank asked do you
uh denounce white supremacy and he said
i've always denounced any form of that
i can go back and read for you um in
august 2019
and one voice our nation must condemn
racism bigotry and white supremacy in
august of 2017
racism is evil and those who cause
violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the kkk neo-nazis
white supremacists and other hate groups
i have an entire list of these quotes
that i can go through with you
he is condemned why is privacy more than
any president in modern history
just to clear it up this morning can you
naming it make a declarative statement
that you deny that the president
denounces
i just did but again the narrative above
all the media are worth
points to the democrats a few weeks ago
the democratic narrative
pushed by the media and pushed by social
media is that voter suppression was on
the horizon
that donald trump was going to steal the
election via screwing around with the
votes
now when donald trump questions voter
fraud and voter irregularity he's the
bad guy
but one of those democrats pushing the
idea that voter irregularities were
commonplace
it was considered a narrative worth
hearing about donald trump was overtly a
threat to democracy this was a message
pushed by the democratic party
laundered through the media and then
pushed into social media at exorbitant
rates
for example here's barack obama saying
that donald trump is trying to
discourage people from voting
what we've seen in a way that is unique
to modern political history
is a president who's explicit trying to
discourage people from voting
what we've never seen before is
a president say i'm going to try to
actively kneecap
the postal service to encourage voting
and i
will be explicit about the reason i'm
doing it yeah that's sort of unheard of
it was also aoc saying that donald trump
was attacking the post office that he
was going to go out and burn the
mailboxes
the postal service is how is not only
how we send a ballot
it is how we get our medicine it is how
we send rent checks it's where people
are getting their tax refunds
it is a core service of any
civilized society and an attack on our
postal service
and an attempt to dismantle our postal
service
out of a selfish desire to sabotage our
democracy
and and maintain a grip on power is an
attack on
all of us this crap was pushed by the
media you had rachel maddow almost
literally crying
about the postal service it's how we get
our letters it's how we get our ballots
now because of the covid crisis it's the
freaking fracking mail we need it
but this is a fight against a thing that
americans
actually and quite broadly love
and respect and don't want to go away
this is the kind of fight that most
americans have a side they want to be on
and it is not the side that is stealing
the mailboxes and telling us that
yeah it doesn't thank you i don't think
it's going to work out for you to get
your ballot in on time
no oh that was just a lie it just wasn't
true but didn't matter it was pushed out
anyway
so for four long years all we heard was
donald trump is a white supremacist
donald trump is a russian colluder
donald trump is trying to undermine
american democracy
and destroy the republic from the inside
and then finally we had the media
pushing all these polls that ended up
being pretty much complete garbage
so you know bad on me i reported the
polls because i assumed wrongly that
pollsters had attempted to correct their
mistakes apparently they not only didn't
correct their mistakes they blew it even
worse than they did the last time
by the way one of the reasons the
pollsters blew it is because the
pollsters
didn't detect a shy trump effect what
was the shy trump effect it was
members of the general american public
who would not tell pollsters they were
voting for trump and would not tell
their friends they were voting for trump
you know why they wouldn't tell their
friends they were voting for trump i'll
give you a hint
it has to do with that iron triangle
democrats would push a message like
donald trump was evil
the media would pick up that message
that message would get pushed around on
social media
and then you wouldn't want to tell any
of your friends because you're afraid
you would get cancelled
you're afraid your boss would fire you
and so you didn't tell the pollsters
so you had the media pushing these these
polls about how trump was getting blown
out in wisconsin it was narrow i was
getting blown out in michigan it was
narrow he's getting blown out in
pennsylvania it was narrow
they had all of these polls being pushed
and the polls turned out not to be right
the media were not worth eight to ten
points for joe biden in this election
they were worth all the points for joe
biden in this election
joe biden literally sat in his basement
and did nothing and the media asked him
about what flavor of ice cream he was
eating
they accused donald trump meanwhile of
killing 200 000 people
joe biden laid out this message here is
joe biden laying out the message
220 000 americans dead
if you hear nothing else i say tonight
hear this
anyone is responsible for not taking
control
in fact not saying i'm i take no
responsibility initially
anyone who's responsible for that many
deaths should not remain as president of
the united states of america
and then of course he had brianna keeler
of cnn basically laying out that message
too just right in unison there are 220
417 reasons to talk about
coronavirus there are nearly 60 000
cases per day in the u.s in rising
the person whose response has failed on
most objective
measures is not fixing his government's
approach to the crisis
instead he's suggesting we just ignore
it the president doesn't even regularly
acknowledge
the huge loss of life that we've
experienced here in the last nine months
in fact he has instead questioned
whether that horrifying number is
accurate
two hundred twenty thousand dead
meanwhile if you questioned
the policies of andrew cuomo if you
questioned lockdown policy
if you questioned actually the
differential rates of
covet deadliness via population tranche
you were at risk of being censored by
youtube
your risk of being censored by facebook
and twitter okay this is the game this
is the game and this is going to be the
game
for the foreseeable future the media
were worth the margin of the election to
joe biden
many times over here moving forward the
media have completely undercut their
credibility in pursuit of trump
so what are we going to do about it we
got to build an alternative media
we have to build a replacement for the
media the media do not deserve your
trust
they do not deserve your dollars we're
trying to do that over here at daily
wire this is why you should come
subscribe over at daily wear but you
shouldn't just subscribe to daily wire
you should go subscribe to our friends
at blaze tv you should give a donation
of prague are you
you should support alternative sources
of information because the media
cannot be trusted not to twist elections
they cannot be trusted not to lie to you
and suppress information and declare
themselves the defenders of democracy
in doing so